elon musk used to own plenty of real
estate in california but in 2020 he went
on a huge selling spree
parting ways with his multi-million
dollar properties one
by one by one buy one in total he sold
seven houses
his eighth and only remaining home a
beautiful bay area estate that he
describes as a special place
hit the market in june the price 37.5
million not long ago musk packed his
bags and moved to texas which by the way
has no personal income
tax whereas the golden state imposes the
highest level of income tax on its
residents
there are plenty of fancy homes in south
texas a half hours drive from boca chica
where spacex built its rocket facility
for starship
but the second richest person in the
world says instead he's chosen to rent a
small home from his company located by
the production site worth a mere
50 000. he reportedly lives in a
foldable house in a box like this
according to teslarati
the windows and walls unfold into a 400
square foot space complete with a
kitchen
bathroom bedroom and living room they're
built by a startup called
boxable which had no comment about
musk's living situation when i reached
out to them
but the company has certainly been
dropping hints about a new customer
in a promotional video from late 2020
boxable showed off one of its units with
a photo of spacex's falcon 9
and had this to say about a special
delivery we just installed in boca chica
texas
for a top secret customer the portable
homes have a starting price of 49
500 and are light enough to be towed by
a model x
which costs twice as much by living on
site musk has 24 7 access to all of
spacex's developments
as it powers full steam ahead in the
hopes of sending humans to mars
musk has famously signaled his
commitment to his companies by placing
himself right in the center of the
action
like the times he sleeps at tesla's
factories which i talked about in
another video
or further back when he and his brother
started their first company
he slept at the office and showered at
the ymca in this case
his vision of a factory line of fully
reusable launch vehicles
supersedes any desire for luxurious
living
downsizing his house as a metaphor for
downsizing his life
in order to focus on his ambitions and
if making life multi-planetary weren't
enough
he's trying to solve traffic congestion
with a boring company
wants to make humans smarter by
implanting tiny wires with neuralink
and then of course there's his electric
car company tesla which has a
gigafactory under construction in austin
his girlfriend grimes confirmed she has
also moved to the texas capital
musk is not the only billionaire to live
frugally facebook's mark zuckerberg
famously has a wardrobe of simple
gray shirts one of the most successful
investors of all time
warren buffett often eats breakfast at
mcdonald's and still lives in the same
house in omaha that he purchased in 1958
for 31 still it's nothing like a tiny
home
in a box musk has also been seen at
another property in boca chica village
right next to spacex's site
the ceo has been spotted staying at this
house that spacex remodeled
and is said to be one of the nicest in
the neighborhood it was appraised at 47
000 in 2020 and is now worth more than
three times that according to the wall
street journal
real estate in boca chica has soared in
value since musk appealed for people to
move to the area and said spacex would
have thousands of job openings in the
next few years
bokuchika is a tiny community there are
only about 40 houses here
with no shops restaurants or even water
pipes water is trucked in
the people who live here are mostly
retired and come to spend the winters
spacex has been offering to buy all the
houses some residents have taken the
money while others have refused and have
complained of bullying by spacex to try
and get them to sell
south texas is precious to spacex
because of its proximity to the equator
which gives rockets a boost in speed due
to the rotation of the earth
the company also has a long history in
the lone star estate it's at a rocket
engine testing site north of austin for
two decades
spacex has hinted that it wants to
develop the boko chica area into a
resort
it posted a job for a resort development
manager in 2020.
musk envisions a city called starbase
that would incorporate the small
community
boxable has even pitched the idea of
more housing units for the expansion of
starbase
as for this fifty thousand dollar humble
abode musk is unlikely to buy million
dollar digs in the future he has said
his plan is to not own a home
who needs one when mars is calling to
call musk a busy man
is an understatement he reportedly plans
his day
in five minute slots in order to make
the best use of his time
if you'd like to learn how to be more
productive maybe not on the scale of
musk but productive nonetheless
my sponsor skillshare can help and you
can try it out for free
the first one is simply scheduling
author and video creator
thomasfrank helps me organize and
improve my workflow as i craft my
stories
skillshare can also help you get better
at making videos with classes on editing
creating animations and designing
standout youtube thumbnails
there are thousands of inspiring classes
broken up into short lessons
there are no ads and it's for all skill
levels the first 1000 people who use the
link in my description will receive a
one month
free trial of skillshare premium
for news think i'm cindy palm
[Music]